dude I would get these really annoying
comments from the wild and Out Days
random dudes on forums would be like I
tend to sell out because he gets on that
show and lets everyone make Asian jokes
to him
like what are you supposed to do is [__]
him I'm like yeah fight everybody do you
not watch literally 10 seconds later
when I clap back I won't stutter it you
talking about my
word
and I'm up there like we're going back
and forth I'm like literally defending
our people up there to get all riled up
and go you hurt my feelings that makes
you a [__] yo DJ Cut the music why'd
you say that ah cool dude the better
thing is to keep cool play along and
then [__] destroy them in the game
yeah man I love Benihana's I really like
your mama because you did that uh you
know my mom told me about that she said
it was amazing because when she seen you
she thought you was Asian
[Applause]